cdc director dr rachelle wolinski she
joins us now from washington good to see
you dr wilinski let's let's get right to
let's pick up where david left off
because the research is so clear on this
that the vaccine definitely is saving
lives yet parents are saying i'm taking
a wait-and-see attitude i'll get it for
myself but not when it comes to my child
in addition to what david just said
what can you tell us what can you tell
parents rather who were still hesitant
please tell them something they don't
know that maybe they don't understand
yes good morning gail this is just
really exciting news that we now have
vaccine recommendations for 28 million
children between the ages of 5 to 11. we
at the advisory committee reviewed a lot
of data yesterday we looked at the risks
of disease the risks of death of
hospitalizations of long covet among
children and importantly we looked at
how well these vaccines work
91 percent
effective against infection and then of
course we reviewed the safety data there
were no severe events associated with
the safety of this vaccine and in fact
we see the side effects of this vaccine
that are very similar to what we've seen
it in adults and the most common of
which is a sore arm which goes away in
about a day or two so the overwhelming
evidence for parents to really know and
understand is that the benefit of this
vaccine so much outweigh the risks of
covet itself
but when it comes to your child you're
still scared you know you'll do
something for yourself but you you won't
do it for your child i i don't think
it's enough for people to say that
the benefits outweigh it
absolutely and we want to we we
recognize that this is a new vaccine
we've taken the time to get this right
so we had vaccine almost a year ago now
for adults and we have taken the time to
get this right for our children this is
a child-sized dose as noted it was
one-third the dose we've done the
clinical trials in children between the
ages of 5 to 11 we've done the
incredible due diligence to take the
time to get it right and we know parents
have questions and we want to give
parents the information that they need
communicate with them have them ask the
questions of their trusted messengers
here their pediatricians their
pharmacists and that's where we will be
distributing the vaccine
dr winsky i have an 11 year old and a 17
year old now i know that younger
children will receive one third of the
dose can you break that down and explain
why
you know um we want to make you know
young people are not just
small older people and we need to with
all vaccines we we have different doses
with all medications we actually have
different doses and so what they've done
in these clinical trials is to look at
dose de-escalation to make sure that the
younger children are getting the right
dose both to balance the effectiveness
and make sure that it's actually working
well and to make sure there were no side
effects and they absolutely hit that
sweet spot at this dose
all right dr wolinski this is very
encouraging news for a lot of people we
thank you for your time this morning
thanks so much get your children
vaccinated yeah